hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to happy
Independence Day everybody let's
celebrate by reviewing independence ah
this what we hate it so much and yet I
always find out that I'm part of a small
minority on this I mean great it was a
critical flop than when this movie first
came out I was excited to see Schiphol a
lot but if you get past the explosions
there is nothing creative or original
about this movie it's just human
stereotypes trying to fight off alien
stereotypes nothing more let's so many
people keep telling you it's a blend of
good movies give you cheesy food well
let me tell you something a waterslide
is fun all the slipping and sliding it's
just great but if someone took you off
the waterslide shook you get your loogie
and that's bad in your face and put you
back on the waterslide you'd be like
that wasn't fun
that was we've done annoying and that's
this movie so let's celebrate
Independence Day with Independence Day
so we start off with a bright flash if
we see something hovering over the moon
boy this is like the opening shot from
that other sci-fi movie what was it
called again
Talia suburban commando another bright
flash appears as we cut to the
extraterrestrial intelligence Institute
or just now noticing that the spaceship
is approaching earth I guess it was just
hiding behind the moon the whole time
cut to another stinking flash as we're
suddenly in Washington where we see our
president played by Bill Pullman young
star was not happy about sleeping pills
that's the problem they elected a
warrior and I got a wimp oh is the Obama
administration yes can you say that
again
damn it will you knock it off with those
bright flashes your movie isn't a
fucking magic show watch everybody as I
magically switch locations here we see
two people playing chess and yeah
there's really no point prolonging this
anymore
cast step forward and state your
stereotype unjust I'm the Jewish
stereotype
I'm Robert legaia I'm a gruff military
stereotype I'm Randy Quaid even on the
redneck stereotype Adam brings fire and
I'm the geeky stereotype I'm that guy
from mrs. Doubtfire and I would get a
stereotype I'm Harry Connick jr. now the
annoying bestfriend stereotype I am Jeff
Goldblum and I am in enough myself on a
stereotype so with a cast like that how
can't an alien race be tempted to wipe
out all that Earth has to offer as they
send out their giant mechanical sand
dollars to cover the globe
I swear to God if I see another flash
I'm gonna shut this movie up roll with
Network she's dead I don't want to add
to a public hysteria that's gonna cost
lives and what happens if they do become
hostile so we cut the Randy Quaid who's
a drunk redneck pilot who actually
claims to have been abducted by aliens
before Russ when they took you up in
their spaceship did they do any sexual
thing you recollect I don't need this if
I wanted to be laughed at and go back to
Hollywood so the aliens arrived and
placed themselves conveniently over
America's most famous monuments but that
doesn't stop our other main character
Will Smith getting jiggy with it on his
girlfriend vivica a fox you're going out
daily shooting games no you shoot
nailing Israel you must resist Minh and
black Joe must resist women black joke
and I have to admit this is the only
character who doesn't suck not because
of the writing or anything but because
it's fucking Will Smith the king of cool
he can make anything sound awesome he's
like the most charming man alive I don't
even know what it is there's just
something about
[Music]
Oh July booths but seriously he can make
anything sound good
look at this very basic scene and listen
to how he makes it so cool uh-huh come
on now you can't go you got to call them
back I'm not gonna do this with you
Jasmine but you said you was on leave
for the 4th why are you acting like this
why that's why he's gorgeous I really
don't think they flew 90 billion
light-years to come down yet start a
fight look at this bit the line is
you're not as charming as you think you
are and Will Smith just says yes I am
what a terrible line who the hell would
write that away listen to him say it but
you're not as charming as you think you
are sir yes I am but more important
things are going on like how our
government with all their scientific
technology discovers that the alien
ships are using our old satellites
against us sending out a signal that
will eventually run out and probably
beat an attack oh wait no sorry this was
figured out by one cable repairman whose
job is to make sure that your HBO is
coming in clear FBI TV maintenance the
whole prison where it's like a chess
first to strategically position your
pieces and when the timings right you
strike their position ourselves all over
the world proximate least six hours
the signals gonna disappear the
countdowns gonna be over and then what
good lord
if golden can make just about anything
overdramatic candy even then the scene
that is overdramatic he makes it even
more overdramatic how is it your cold
one can turn anything into a melodrama
yes I would like to I'll return this
taco to you because there was uh uh uh
no sauce on it and uh as we all know
when there is uh no sauce on the taco
you will realize that it is not spicy
and ah bah bah blah if it is not spicy
uh well then do you all know that means
oh my god I gotta call my brother I
better call my housekeeper I gotta call
my lawyer I got a call Disney I let him
know I won't be able to do Mulan five so
Jeff Goldblum and his father head to the
White House to try and warn them yeah so
tell me something are you so smart how
come you spend eight years and MIT to
become a cable repairman all I'm saying
is they got people or handle these
things David look at these look at these
people look closest they take and then
they go they're going they're going
faster than we are look at it on the
fast lane I can't go faster they're
cutting me off here no one's cutting you
off then we're gonna go ticket in front
of me I can't go any faster so randy
quaid tries his best against family away
from the inn we got his son is ashamed
of his father his daughter who's a
complete slut and the third one who's
the third one but another that we see
Will Smith and his friend Harry Connick
jr. as it seems will has been turned
down again to join NASA me you know I
really like jasmine you know that right
may you never gonna get the flight of
space shuttle if you marry a stripper
that's right his fiance's a stripper and
because of that I guess Nestor doesn't
think you'll be mentally sound you know
because the space program has produced
some real examples of mental health in
the past few years happen so Gollum and
his father finally get to the White
House
goddamn tea partiers but it's okay they
have a way inside how well it turns out
Goldblum happens to have an ex-wife who
works for the White House isn't that a
happy little coincidence I would never
believe in my lifetime that I would be
at the White House what is it if I knew
I was gonna meet the president I would
have won on ty I mean look at me I look
like a schlemiel
Shalom vomits but I mention I'm Jewish
so he convinces the president that they
have less than a half hour until Boone's
bill so the kid the president how does
one helicopter tries to make contact
with this shit Welcome Wagon has
commenced
you may fire when ready meanwhile the
president's wife who's in another
location is told to evacuate as well and
our prayers go out to the wives and
children of those brave pilots indeed
god help us always really the newscaster
just said god help us all
isn't that the equivalent of saying Oh
hurricane was spotted on the eastern
coast panic
so the ships finally start to open up as
golden seats the clock has ticked its
last seconds time shaft oh hey yeah push
that button over there which is oh yeah
[Music]
so the earth is on fire is Will Smith's
fiance wishes for cover
yeah hi there
the explosion will never think to look
for you there
yes what about blue dude lady you have a
kid with you fuck the dog and just close
the damn door luckily the explosions too
polite to enter through an open door so
I guess they'll be safe after all so
July 3rd it's as we look over the
aftermath the aliens have left behind
the advantage of being a fighter pilot
Gulf War we knew what we had to do oh
hey look at the bright side
could have been an illegible so in a
kinder kid or a shock to find that Duck
and Cover ship really works as they grow
much fuck and start looking for
survivors yeah but did boomer make it
okay
[Music]
meanwhile Will Smith in the rest of the
fighter pilots head up to kick some
alien ass bring that bad boy home cap
you lose your side got your victory
dance well I got it right here yeah
oh wow you are so dead as the good
Reverend would say what we all this
particular mission we'll never know but
I do know here today that the Black
Knights will emerge victorious once
again
amen amen Reverend hey you know what
else I love living
I love living I hope to do a lot of
living while I'm still alive
I'm just so lively wouldn't it be a
great tragic irony if I was to not be
living wouldn't it be the most dramatic
contrast that only a b-movie there's
somehow got a bajillion dollar budget
we'll put together god I love being
alive alive macaroon but unfortunately
the ship has some sort of refreshing
mint shield as the alien pilots come out
to kill the fight
damn they got you too let's get low
let's get fast
I got you Big Daddy let's get him come
on Barrow load
oh and here's the big shocker right for
this is just like a big shocker holy
smudging I can't believe this I mean
it's just incredible I mean are you
ready erase it that's really incredible
are you write the best
oh my god but kill Jimmy you bastards
so one of the alien pilots chases Will
Smith through the desert when they
perform some stunts that quite frankly
would be too silly for the hotshot
movies to pull off see if you can fly
that thing under cover
[Music]
all of your base are belong to us
welcome to earth that's where I call a
close encounter but meanwhile the
president and his men trying to figure
out what they're going to do next and
here's what in the nineteen 150 sir
whatever you you had that spaceship oh
god you're nuts well well smell the
Mexico yeah no you had the spaceship any
antibodies you're not really going that
direction are you area 51 right
area 51 regardless of what you may have
read in the tabloids there have never
been any spacecraft recovered by our
government Oh Joyce you know for a
second I really thought you'd be stupid
enough dick that's not entirely accurate
you know I'll believe it when I see that
I don't believe it you're actually
saying that area 51 really was an alien
that you never brought it to anyone's
attention while the ships were landing
stand back he's gonna go for it he's
gonna go for it shark so we see brent
Spiner also known as data from Star Trek
as the head scientists since these guys
started showing up all the little gizmos
inside turned on I'm confused what do
these two characters wasn't human again
don't know who cares we have more
implausible meetups to combine
now let's see what should we do here I
know let's see Viveca a fox
coincidentally runs into the first lady
and Will Smith coincidentally runs into
Randy Quaid who coincidentally runs into
the secret base which coincidentally has
the president in it well that's all fine
and good but boomer make it out okay
[Music]
so they decided to perform an operation
of an alien to see what's inside Ridge
hey here's a crazy idea
um why don't you have some security
around I mean you know these aliens want
to kill you say something went wrong I
mean what if for some crazy reason you
didn't give him anaesthetic he wakes up
amid some ear piercing sound max and all
the power kills the doctors and uses the
body of one of them to communicate with
other people I mean I'm just saying so
the alien tries to do some mines ever
thing with the president as the security
finally takes the alien up meanwhile Lou
Smith decides that he wants to steal a
helicopter to look for his fiancee oh
yeah
look I got something I got a handle I'm
just borrowing it no you're not sir do
you really want to shoot me
damn that Mel Smith chart next time I
gotta try that just go up to a military
helicopter and be like hey I need this
there's something I gotta do
I didn't ever thought just to ask it's
practically foolproof and wins you know
it in the middle of the night without
any signals without any clue of her
location he just happens to stumble
across her you're late
you know I'd like to make an entrance in
this moment brought to you by the loss
of improbability so they really like the
president with his wife but
unfortunately she's bleeding internally
and can't be fixed
[Music]
JJ felt like we barely knew her that's
because we did barely know her maybe we
didn't have 30 other characters in this
movie we would feel bad that this person
got
[Music]
Oh No
this is giving me an emotion must not
act mas not alright
oh good I made it to the next credit but
the president isn't the only one having
problem a fucking Jeff Goldblum screams
in anger and seeks the aid of his fuck
everyone loses faith at some point in
their life myself I haven't spoken to
God since your mother died well there's
dead you still have your health
well Goldblum suddenly gets an idea to
get the alien mothership a virus because
now this TV repairman can not only find
signals that the government's top men
can't find but apparently can also have
alien technology while only being aware
of it for one day my god is there
anything you can't do no but still they
can either pilot to fly that alien ship
who are they getting it I've seen these
things in action and I'm well aware of
their maneuvering capabilities with your
permission general I'd like the
opportunity to try yes let that man fly
that ship what's that
his fiance is a stripper bring them back
bring them bad we can't allow that
though so smoothness Beyonce finally get
married right before they head up to
infect the mothership an alien race that
wipes out earth but it's killed by our
viruses who ever heard of such a thing
Fisher goth so once they head off into
space our president gets ready to make
the biggest speech for the trailer the
fourth of July will no longer be known
as an American holiday but as the day
when the world declared in one voice we
will not
quietly into the night today we
celebrate our Independence Day
boy thank god this all went down at
Independence Day I mean can you imagine
what would happen this took place on a
lesser holiday today I'm talking like a
pirate day we celebrate our right to
talk like pirates and we want you coming
on a bill third tunic we show against
dirty dogs those busts whose and just
when you think this movie couldn't get
any more silly cliches
mr. president I'd sure like to know what
you're doing combat pilot well I belong
in the air that's right
the president of the free world is
flying up in the air with the other
fighter pilots yeah sure let him fly
with the other fighter pilot I mean it's
just the president it's not like you'll
be needed for anything else it's not
like there's any choice decisions that a
democracy chose him to make just a
little man is fun yeah well fuck it
Will Smith and Jeff Goldblum flying to
the mothership to inflate the virus now
this raises another question an alien
ship from the 1950s isn't gonna cause
any suspicion from the other aliens over
40 years of technological advancements
must have happened over that time and
they just blend in like one of the other
ships does one of the main aliens just
think he knows who the alien is in there
Stephanie Stephanie is that you oh my
god I haven't seen you what are your
shit system
Tony how's your Aunt Flo but that is the
reason why you said you'd be away for a
while right it's dead Stephanie they
have a oh do not engage until we've
confirmed some fighter pilots led by the
president trying to seal his next
campaign poster why are there missiles
at the ship who should hit their shields
down Maya
hold on command
I want another shudder
these ladies are tic-tacs profession
minora
Stephani letters why aren't you talking
to me it's because I slept with your 8
million sisters look they came on to me
okay hey wait a minute
it's because you want me to see your
pretty face isn't it let me just open up
the window here so I can see your eyes
one more Stephanie were you always
invisible one box good oh maybe you
should have let a professional pilot fly
doesn't anyone have any missiles left
pilot you are armed and ready sir who is
that guy
what am i speaker who is that brave will
in America that we all underestimate
it's me okay but his missile gifts
jammed as he decides to do the noble
thing and sacrifice his life for the
world
really
so all this advanced scientific weaponry
and the answer was the equivalent of a
cartoon character put his finger in a
gun
I guess cartoon logic saves the day can
I have a won every squadron around the
world
tell them how to bring those sons of
bitches down tell them to get all the
drunks suicidal redneck pilots they can
find Stephanie you can't hide from our
love I really thought we had something
there I felt a connection something
cosmic if you will yes did you do
something to your hair
we're Luke's you guys out here 30
seconds so they get themselves loose
they fly through the ship of dried up
dog turds and golden delights and
flipping off Jurassic Park must go
faster must go faster hey you know what
I need get it to think that wasn't
Stefan
so all the other ships are taken down
Goldblum and Smith get home safe and the
president has declared a hero actually
no a drunk redneck pilot did this mommy
is still alive yeah we'll have to have a
talk later
so they all live happily ever after
boomer I mean granted I did kind of like
it as a kid but as an adult it's just
too corny and to cliched the characters
are unbelievable cutouts the story has
about a bajillion Platt holes and no I
don't need anything else that's enough
to eat this movie I will say this though
the explosions are cool the spaceships
are cool on Will Smith is cool these are
some of the worst films I've ever
reviewed no but it's still bad it's
really really bad and let's face it ever
since the directors been trying to make
the same movie over and over and over
fancying house already rumor that
there's gonna be an Independence Day - I
have just one question for you who
decided to get a B on the humans or the
aliens no no no no I'm the Nostalgia
Critic I remember it so you don't have
to
[Music]
Yeah right